[Musique]
les policiers sont arrivés ces lieux
c'est un couple qui était sur place et
de son médecin nous dans le même centre
hospitalier
les premiers intervenants la cellule
agir élabore rapidement des solutions
pour venir en aide aux victimes
oui ça va on a reçu un appel concernant
que décrit à votre adresse martin
métivier chef de la division urgences
sociales à la ville de laval a convoqué
ses partenaires sociaux habituels
le groupe a accepté de simuler une
réunion de prévention de féminicide
georges ezaley changé inspiré du
scénario de formation que nous avons
capté à l'école nationale de police du
québec en cours d'intervention madame as
commencé à se confier leur open cl les
facteurs de risque qui préoccupe le plus
les intervenants sont d'abord
l'historique de violence qu'elle soit
physique ou psychologique qui parle des
nuits blanches à l'empêcher de dormir à
vérifie justement dans dans son
cellulaire ses contacts et la rupture
annoncée ou imminente de la relation du
couple
il est une ville qu'elle voulait partir
mais que ceux ci partir il partira
certainement postule donc à damas des
menaces dommage que madame ne seraient
rencontrés inquiétant pour un autre
partage pendant leur formation de caisse
semaine à l'école nationale de police du
québec
les aspirants policiers sont confrontés
à des simulations de violence conjugale
comme celle ci se gagnent les y
consacrent 27 heures sur près de 500 au
total
dès qu'on a des motifs raisonnables de
croire qu'il ya des voies de fait que
été commis ou à des menaces de mort des
choses comme ça d'intervenir rapidement
procédé à l'arrestation du suspect
[Musique]
oui les groupes devront venir protéger
les victimes malheureuses la police
c'est vraiment un moment bien précis
au moment où se produit la crise d'aider
les victimes puis les mettre en sécurité
on va prioriser la demande de monsieur
donc on va l'évaluer vont un peu plus
quels sont les éléments dangerosité donc
procéder des estimations du risque
suicidaire et un missile ce monsieur
encore d'accusation violences conjugales
mais n'y a pas d'interdît avec madame
fait qu'on ne pose de filets de
protection là pour les listes un vaudois
de vaisseaux spatiaux avec temps prêt
demandé à madame horse avait hébergé ont
préservé une place en attendant chose
qu'on fait pas souvent mais
effectivement je pense que tout les
éléments démontre qu'il faut défécation
en sécurité à partir des informations
recueillies par les premiers
intervenants la cellule agir élabore
rapidement des solutions pour venir en
aide aux victimes et tenter de traiter à
plus long terme les agresseurs bien 26
ans elle l'arbre cachant ses mots de
passe et les publications sur facebook
peut accueillir limiter temporairement y
avait d'autres choses à regarder depuis
1998 agir à traiter 84 cas de violence
conjugale avec risque d'homicide
il n'y a eu aucun décès lié à ces
dossiers il y a eu nous dit on trois ou
quatre fiminy side pendant cette même
période
des cas qui n'avait pas été référée à la
cellule de crise que c'est un modèle qui
facilement applicables ailleurs d'après
vous je pense que chaque service de
police est capable de faire cette
démarche
non on détient point délai de 24 heures
l'expérience d'agir à laval démontre que
les policiers sont responsables du
signalement de risque de féminicide dans
25% des cas les autres proviennent des
maisons d'hébergement et des
travailleurs sociaux
quand est arrivée la face apeurer les
yeux qui nous balade l'appui à la boule
bleue noter vous déplaît oui comme dans
une cellule quant à miss après-midi
piste
je tends l'autre personnage d'une autre
personne seulement 30% des femmes
victimes de violences conjugales décide
ou acceptent de porter plainte contre
leurs conjointes
mais ce qui est arrivé ce matin c'est un
événement oui fanchone isolé mais l'on
peut pas se permettre que tout le monde
se mette à savoir seuls à l'école de
police comme dans la vraie vie c'est la
réalité
encore aujourd'hui on va se donner 1 48
heures pour laisser la situation évoluer
comme d'habitude je vais vous envoyer un
courriel avec le plan d'intervention
concertée jeu peut que perdre son
travail à cause de cette histoire loves
company